Ashley is in Detroit Michigan
I actually how are you hi Dave good how
are you doing better than I deserve
what's up well I'm just calling because
I'm having a little bit of trouble
getting my husband to stick to the
budget that we have agreed on so I just
kinda wanted to get your opinion on or
what I should do next
how long have y'all been married we have
been married we will be married 6 16
years 17 years in default how long is he
he is 40 what's he do for a living he's
a superintendent for a construction
company they do all automotive plants
and actually he just was transferred out
of town to work on the drives then they
just they just got hit ya know the
projects that he was working on if he
didn't stick to the budget that he had
agreed to as part of the estimate they
would fire his butt exactly and so why
is it he can't stay with the budget he
agreed to with his wife well you know I
don't know if it's because he's out of
town he's bored out of his mind when
he's not at work she's staying in a
hotel so he doesn't have you know a lot
of storage space for you know to buy
groceries and so you know here at home
we're doing the beans and rice and he's
you know going out to eat several times
a week and so I'm just I'm trying to
give him ideas like peanut butter and
jelly doesn't take up a lot of room in
the refrigerator you know and I don't
know if he's just so he there one of two
things is going on either he's not
really agreed to do this thing or you
guys have set an unrealistic number for
him I don't know which it is
is he being unreasonable an immature
little boy whining or have you clamped
him down too hard because you're a super
nerd it might be a little bit of both
might be um you know I think I'm I'm
really really excited about this you
know and I know
he says verbally that he is and that
he's on board and you know its actions
his actions aren't saying it so here's
what I Monday this guy is the kind of
guy who believes in keeping his word he
would be highly offended if someone lied
to him
he's an he's a person of honor isn't he
yeah yeah I think I mean I've worked
with a lot of guys just like him and I
am that kind of guy come out that same
heritage and so I would just call him
out on that and say okay we've got to
set a number here that we can both agree
to stick to because you're a man of
honor and you've been breaking your word
and that's just not like you and that's
not okay call him out on that that this
is a contract or when we agree to this
number we're gonna pinkie swear and spit
shake and I'm gonna break your knuckles
if you break the contract you know he
needs to hear that that he gave his word
he's kind of playing your little
financial thing while he's out down
working and he can't do that anymore
it's got to be more serious than that
it's got to be a contract where he signs
it in blood because if he gets that in
his emotions he would never break his
work he's not that guy and that's how
you're viewing it because for you it was
a contract and but he he's just not a
person that breaks his work that's not
who he is I'm not hearing that this is
not a little boy who's immature and
uncapable this guy's a man he's a good
man yeah he'd you just guys have not you
guys have not looked at this commitment
at the same level and so you've got up
you got to ramp up your language on how
we look at this contract pinkie swear
spit shake in blood if you do this I'm
if you break your word again me and you
were gonna have a problem and he's gonna
laugh and go yeah okay I get it
that's who this guy is okay because he
didn't he didn't he didn't hear contract
he heard suggestion yes okay you're
right I think so I'll just be a little
more Stern well and it's just it's not
it's not you being
his mom's turn it's clarifying language
so you're tapping into his honor and the
integrity of the man that is there
instead of like oh this is cute it's
hurdle thing she's working on okay is
that because I can do that so if Sharon
goes look we said we're gonna be there
at 6:30 you know what we're there at 625
because the trains run on time you know
but if it's like well they said come
somewhere between 6:30 and 7:00 we'll
roll in there somewhere between 6:30 and
7:00 but if it was 6:30 then that would
it be a screwed up deal you know so we
got to have real clarity on what's going
on and then we we do that so a good
question thank you for joining us it's a
good clarification because I tell you
what men the number one thing couples
fight about even good people even good
marriages and that lady you could tell
by the language and the tone and the way
she was discussing him that she wasn't
dealing with an immature little boy in a
man's body and sometimes wives are
dealing with that a little worse you
know a little boy and God help you women
if you marry a little boy and God help
you men if you marry a princess because
it's just you know you need to marry
like full grown people where their
emotions are full grown too it changes
everything it's a different thing and so
she wasn't using any of that language
she was using very clear language and
you could tell and the reason I asked
about his age how long they've been
married what he does for a living it
gives me indicators of every bit of that
and this guy's running a large project
management situation for construction
from out of town he's used to doing
numbers he's used to hitting schedules
he's used to doing things on time he's
used to doing things right and when he
doesn't there are consequences very easy
to transfer that set of skills and that
view of life into simply doing a
household budget together and so that
that's that's well you know you can
listen to these things you can hear them
in these callers as people call in in
their lives on the other hand you get
the guy and the and you can't keep a job
doesn't like to work much
you know and he's trying to figure out a
way all the time to trick something or
scam something or scheme something this
guy can't be nailed down to anything and
the same thing if you switch it from guy
to gal it's not a it's not a picking on
men thing it's a you know picking on
people thing because we gotta be
grownups to win at these different areas
of our lives and those that couple
there's got it they got a lot of the
they got the skills they got the stuff
sixteen years of marriage and the way
she was she wasn't whining about her
husband she's just trying to figure out
a system a process to communicate better
the whole different things see how that
works that's why we take good marriages
in Financial Peace University and make
them great and sometimes how we take a
marriage is on the rocks and save it and
we're not even in the marriage business
but it's the number one thing people
fight about money and money problems and
that is probably always been that way
all the research tells us that